bella tutti ragazzi sì ma stai calma
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi sono sul forum che
sarebbe un videogame molto bello
praticamente sarebbe un videogame
credo che sia a posso giocare anche
bello mi piace carino switch cam a posso
che figo previamente ragazzi è molto
semplice semplice il concetto in ogni
gioco che dovrei riuscire ad arrivare
porca merda ok non adani notano vista
ieri in particolare dovrebbe essere una
roba tipo world hardest game tipo sono
in 3d che è molto più figo in 3d è
l'obiettivo sarebbe quello di morire
iniziamo a spaccare qualche non sapevi
qualcosa da spaccare dalla parte opposta
ok ok bene no bene bene
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye no bene
così bravo zio perfetto perfetto ok ho
fatto uno ne ho fatto uno ai che figo
posso zoomare la video can't astico
questo torneo kay kay le punte elementi
nel culo to grazie è presente la figura
quella che ti partorisce la figura
materna ecco quella t days morire quella
che non è che ci sono check point i sta
merda di gioco crepi se crepi crepi non
c'è verso non va toccato non ha toccato
da minacciato di denunce se mi toccava
infatti non mi ha toccato il vero
problema ragazzi di questa merda e che è
a tempo impossibile finirlo manca 25
secondi non c'è ormai coccio dei razzi a
propulsione nel culo non ce la faccio
che non ce la farò mai
10 98 dai 98 76 54 madonna tre secondi
che stai bene zio bravo bravo
[Musica]
mancavano tre secondi di merda non so
come fa non mi chiedete loro sorte merde
di spunti manco quello del verificato di
whatsapp è così fastidioso perfetto
perfetto e mi manca tutto il resto che
faccio vado a fare in culo va da fare in
culo perfetto ma e tornò tutto indietro
ci vorrà mai nella vita
432 sticazzi 1 ciao nostra c'è ma cosa
vuoi che faccia ho cliccato restarte mi
ha fatto un altro livello che bello sto
gioco sta dicendo che più carino di the
world game ma non è vero proprio non ne
verrai vai vai vai vai prima katyn
groppi vai sì sì bravo zio bravo zio
perfetto entrato perfettamente nel buco
è così vai così forza e va beh lo zen e
mai nella vita riuscirà a far stare
cos'è state prendendo veramente per il
culo che figo così che figo bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
non hanno non hanno sì che bravo zio avo
bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo bravo
bravo che fa il vino bravo e che per ce
l'ho fatta ragazzi ho fatta perchè non
c'è il tempo adesso perché non sono
ancora se muoio parte del tempo non
capita sta cosa io sì madonna kian se
manco mi avessero messo una supposta
sono riuscito a non morire per tutto il
livello cosa impossibile bello che il
cubo passa in mezzo al dove non può
passare fantastica ragazzi si ok c'è
solo un modo solo per finire sta roba
uno che è quello di prendere l'ultima
cosa e morire niente niente è finita il
bello che finito il livello è finito ok
re start per farlo ripartire
e ce n'è un altro e che è quello di
prima
[Musica]
ma chi come difatti si giochi con buco
del culo
adesso facciamo questo non capite un
cazzo è questo che non ho fatto perfetto
questo non l'avevo fatto prima non ci
sono riuscito e ok va bene così beh
veloce veloce veloce però veloce però 8
secondi 7 secondi sei secondi 54 ho
vinto vito perfetto 9 di 25 ragazzi ce
la potremmo fare in un universo
parallelo finalizzato perfetto
visualizza visualizza bravo ok ok bravo
zio perfetto perfetto bravo ce l'ho
fatta adesso adesso in realtà mi
conviene morire perché se muoio riparto
dall'inizio non sono morto è che riparto
d'acqua e da qua ci arrivo per fare no
no dieci secondi però cielo ci come tua
madre ha letto però c'è no non ci
credono
[Musica]
si no perché madonna madonna perché le
mie mi fa andare avanti qual è il
problema di chi ha creato sto gioco
fatemi capire perché moglie on giu si ok
no no spunta bravo no gli schiaffi in
faccia ma che muore
c'è chi è rai sul quadratino di merda
mai a casa che se go home significa vai
a casa comunque che sarebbe sei ubriaco
quindi vai a casa cagarmi gliele minchia
ecco bravo bravissimo madonna madonna
nervoso spunta bravo
adesso lo morire ok veloce veloce 6 5 4
3 2 1 6
sì sì sì cazzo se si pene cos'è oh mio
dio
e va beh non so voi ecco anche una
bottiglia da lanciarmi faccia non so non
devo neanche scendere dai che la madonna
e va beh devo andare dall'altra perfetto
capito ho capito capito subito
non ho capito un cazzo che hanno piano
piano più no no no no no no no madonna
perfetto perfetto sembra un deficiente
perfetto come melo pupa no ma [ __ ]
per un attimo ho creduto di avere la
gloria e tante donne ma non è stato così
cose cose a caso una laurea per
raccogliere il tasto schifo che cos'è un
macello regala che bordello sì bravo
madonna cosa ho fatto
cosa ho fatto ragazzi gay che ai
diciotto secondi non ce la farò mai
nella vita mai nella vita per ci provo
lo stesso
[Musica]
la donna 10 9 oddio vabbè cos'è 7 6 6
no non è possibile non è possibile se la
fattoria con i criceti canarino i maiali
cavalli lo stecco becco no ma dai perché
perché ragazzi perché me l'ha fatto
saltare col di prima se è andato avanti
a caso per una [ __ ] volta per una che
che si paga il gioco si è pagato bene la
prima volta nel secolo che che un gioco
si vaga nel modo giusto perfetto ok ok
no che sono morto cazzo 7 secondi by
perfetto ok ciò fatta c'è poi mettono
anche valentino rossi che corre in mezzo
alla pista è come faccio ma neanche se
cipro momenti ma come faccio e come se
prendo quelli senza crepare sono morto
da anni un come ma vi drogate non me li
fa neanche rifare vi manda avanti è un
gioco bagnatissimo è bello è che su
steam stato sono passato non so come
tipo vitasnella vabbè è la invece no
adesso non risente adesso non ce la farò
mai che nella vita di passargli timori
se li pongono andare a noi adesso adesso
è partito il tempo a caso è tutto un
caso sto gioco cioè veramente non
ubriachi quando non fate 17 su 25
ragazzi siamo a buon punto
più o meno molto più o meno molto molto
meno che è piovuto ma esco come esco
come esco come innesco come esco come
escort
bravo bravo zio bravissimo bravissimo
dai dai dai dai dai dai
bravo no no no no no no
droghe si fanno i creatori di sti giochi
questo non l'ho fatto ma non lo voglio
fare difficile retto perfetto vai vai
vai che ci fai dai che ce la fai
dai che ce la fai no ce l'avevo fatta
cazzo passa lurido di un cubo passa
perfetto perfetto perfetto ok ok 18 mi
ha fatto andare avanti e non so quanti
me ne mancano perché mi fa fare a caso
questo è il bello o maria che burdel di
stupro il fratello ma cazzo come fa a ok
era sera semplice solo che sono stupido
questa è una complicazione ragazzi
succede di essere stupidi capita dai dai
dai dai dai
bravo perfetto perfetto ok questo fatto
non sono io a maria che bur del tè
stupro al fratello ea sto gioco non so
chi ci piglia seno vinco di stupro la
famiglia niente non ce la faccio
impossibile maria che il casinò di
stupro il cestino niente non c'è vernon
cheadle se si può fare qualcosa non lo
raggiungo ragazzi è un problema questo
che so io ma [ __ ]
guardate ora guarda non mi fa passare è
impossibile arrivo qui passo e non si
può allora [ __ ]
[Musica]
ma qualcuno sai